to paint manufacturers that want to wipe
out potentially hundreds of millions of
dollars in legal obligations cuts in the
issue to the voter
sherwin-williams in ConAgra could have
have enough signatures rather today to
put their initiative on California's
November ballot
the manufacturers want to dedicate
taxpayer money to remove lead paint from
homes in schools now this measure would
undo a pricey court ruling that holds
him accountable for selling the toxic
paint John Blackstone shows us why some
accused the paint makers of brushing off
responsibility when brandi and joseph
glazier purchased their Fairfield
California home four years ago it seemed
like the perfect place to raise their
three children a year after moving in
their youngest son Andrew went to the
doctor for a routine check-up they
called me and said he had elevated lead
levels we were like who what do you mean
like how is that possible the glaziers
found out that old lead-based paint in
the home built in 1927 was contaminating
much of the house well the window sill
tested positive for lead paint you know
and he was just sitting there watching
for daddy sick the glazier said Andrews
lead levels were more than four times
what's considered elevated was there
sort of guilt as a parent did you can't
even describe it lead poisoning can
cause lifelong behavior and learning
problems lower IQ and slowed growth it's
a problem in older homes that's at the
heart of a lawsuit against some of the
companies that made and sold lead paint
every five-year-old knows that if you
make a mess you should clean it up they
need to clean up their mess Mary
Alexander is one of the attorneys in a
lawsuit filed by ten California
municipalities back in 2000 led paint
companies knew that led that they put in
their paint was dangerous toxic to
children
Sherwin Williams and ConAgra deny
Alexander's claim in a statement a
spokesperson on behalf of the companies
told CBS News that's false and the trial
court acknowledged that point citing a
2014 court ruling that said the state of
knowledge about lead paints health
hazards
was admittedly in its nascent or
beginning stage but in its summary
decision the same court said defendants
to varying degrees sold lead paint with
actual and constructive knowledge that
it was harmful last year an appeals
court ordered Sherwin Williams and con
Agra to pay the cost of fixing homes
with lead paint hazards built before
1951 the paint companies are now taking
an entirely different approach to try to
win this case so to get out of this
responsibility they have filed an
initiative and they collected signatures
Sherwin Williams and ConAgra are now
backing California's Healthy Homes and
school bond Act the initiative would
order the rehabilitation of homes and
schools with potential health risks
including lead paint it would cost
taxpayers an estimated four billion
dollars and excuse the paint companies
from liability imposed in the suit this
is not an avoidance of liability under
the case Jones Day partner Tony Diaz
represents Sherwin Williams the purpose
of this initiative is to make that
lawsuit void make that decision void the
ballot initiative will be voted on by
people individuals homeowners and
residents of low-income housing are
concerned about what the impact will be
of this case in the same statement the
spokesperson representing Sherwin
Williams and ConAgra said yes the ballot
measure impacts the companies but also
protects millions of homeowners who
could now be faced with a public
nuisance label on their home but not all
agree the paint companies are
fear-mongering and trying to scare
homeowners the court decision
specifically says that that's not true
Oh Randy and Joseph say they've
repainted their home and Andrew now for
has shown no symptoms of lead poisoning
so far what are your concerns for the
future they said that they don't know
what the lead can actually do to him or
if he's going to have effects they have
no idea or CBS this morning John
Blackstone Fairfield California
you have Sherwin Williams and ConAgra
say that they're working with lawmakers
and local jurisdictions on a possible
statewide legislative solution in the
place of the ballot initiative the
proposal would undo the lawsuit and
require all companies that manufactured
lead paint in California to contributor
total 500 million dollars into a 10-year
lead paint abatement fund for homeowners
statewide Sherwin Williams and ConAgra
would be responsible for nearly one
hundred and seventy million dollars that
remember last week we had the author on
who discovered the problem with the lead
that went water in Flint water so we
know how damaging this letter happened
federal regulations on this because
homes before 1978 we're using lead paint
so if you buy an older home you should
test that home and there are allowances
made that you can have 10 days to have
an inspection of the home good
information